[Music]
jake pushy was busy studying strokes
when news emerged about the coronavirus
a research scientist at the
cerebrovascular center at the university
of saskatchewan
he heard how covid19 was sabotaging
blood vessels
triggering inflammation and causing
blood clots
and he knew he had to act
and so when covid hit and you began to
hear about the symptoms
what went through your head well as a
curious scientist this was an
opportunity to learn something new
i realized that the lining of the blood
vessels
uh just like the lungs that everyone's
worried about with covid
those linings of the blood vessels
should also be an ideal target
for the coronavirus to attack but you
decided to pivot
to look specifically into this why did
you do that
i think as scientists we've also got a
moral obligation
that if we think we can help and
contribute then we
absolutely have to step up and and make
that contribution and do whatever we can
he happened to have a powerful tool in
his arsenal the only one of its kind in
canada
right here at the university of
saskatchewan in saskatoon
under this roof at the canadian light
source lies a synchrotron
a state-of-the-art particle accelerator
offering scientists
a window into the innermost workings of
matter
the synchrotron blasts electrons around
a loop
at nearly the speed of light a process
that
unlocks vast amounts of energy creating
beams of highly focused
light millions of times brighter than
the sun
light that can shine through all kinds
of materials
for jake pushy's research it's tissue
samples
infected with covid19
without the synchrotron we simply
wouldn't be able to do
the majority of our investigations
because we can zoom right in and
look at individual cells and what's
changing with those cells and then we
can zoom out
and look at that effect at the whole
organ and then at the organism
level and what is the hypothesis what
are you
looking at what we're looking at is the
long-term effects
of what may happen in a subset of
individuals
going into the future from the coveted
long-haulers probably about
10 of the cases
of coronavirus infections and we're
hypothesizing some of those
cases probably have this underlying
component of vascular changes that have
occurred and those people are going to
carry those changes with them
into the into the future and it's going
to modify their their
health risks for for lots of other
things
they use tissue samples from covet
infected hamsters
human tissue samples are difficult to
obtain and to handle
as researchers have come to know the
disease better they are focusing on the
body's network of arteries
veins and capillaries that stretch more
than ninety six thousand kilometers
the virus can damage the inner layer of
cells lining every vessel
the endothelium what we do see in the
severe
covid cases is the lining on the on the
inside of the blood vessels
that becomes infected causes
inflammation
and swelling around the blood vessels
and what that causes is for for the
blood vessels to to contract and clamp
down
so there's there's just less area for
that
blood to flow through in the blood
vessels if you just reduce
blood flow to the heart you can have
life-threatening arrhythmias
so disruptions in the contraction of the
heart you can also have
reduced kidney function if there's
reduced blood flow to the kidneys
certainly the brain lots of people
report brain fog
and other cognitive impairments and
these these are all
part and parcel of other vascular
disorders that that have already been
well studied for decades
and we're now pulling a lot of these
pieces together and seeing that they
they do fit into this puzzle with covet
infection
in kovid's wake damaged blood vessels
could form
scar tissue and a lifetime of health
problems
if you've got any scars visible on the
outside of your body
that scar tissue doesn't have pores so
you don't sweat through your scar
you you won't grow hair out of your scar
so the same thing happens
for example in the lung and lots of
those patients are cautioned about
the fact that you know they've they've
got some scar tissue built up in the
lungs that's effectively what this is
and that means that a portion of that
lung tissue is no longer functional
so it's a it's a similar thing with the
changes in the tissue
surrounding blood vessels and we see
this in other vascular
disorders is prolonged inflammation
causes permanent restructuring and
remodeling
we are hearing reports now of some men
having erectile dysfunction
months after having coveted is that
potentially related to blood vessels as
well
well that's a highly vascularized organ
and to get and maintain an erection
that's that's a blood flow problem
right and you need vasodilation you need
those blood vessels to open up
to supply enough blood to that organ to
get an erection
so absolutely any reduction in blood
flow
is going to cause a problem do you think
it's possible that
someone who has had covet and recovered
it will become known that that is a risk
factor for
other things developing later in life
things like dementia and stroke
and and heart disease yes
i'm very confident there's already
some very clear writing on the wall that
dementia
heart disease stroke kidney failure
all kinds of these things look like
they're likely to be at play
even in the cases where people have
recovered and they go back to their
daily lives
they could be harboring significant risk
factors
that they take with them into their
future i think just
getting this information out there that
this isn't like having a flu or a cold
uh is is really important for for people
to to understand
so that they can make the most informed
decision for themselves